have you started wearing a mask around
town I wore master omen to the grocery
they said you have to now you gotta get
in certain places you have to yeah to
get in here you have to but these were
all pre-recorded in win February row
after seeing you hi honey don't do any
sports y'all win hike you shoulda seen
this little spot on the mountain bro it
was muddy but god damn I heard somebody
say who brought the transgender strip or
hiking mudskipper mudskipper Chuck I'm
frickin human I said what should I wear
is it nice to hike dude you're on a hike
I'd say you're gonna [ __ ] party in
WeHo with the runner you way your help
he said just wear some soccer style
stuff you'd have to blow out your hair
for the hike I did 270 yards of mud come
on it's all mud and he's packing him
he's on a four-wheeler he's totally cool
and comfortable
he has dog his hunting dog thriving
Eagles he has a temper he's testing the
mud to make sure it's the temperatures
okay I was raised in the MA [ __ ] yeah
Road almost blew my back out walking up
all that mud yeah we'll get you back Oh
shouts my boy suplex and Philly
shout-out to nobody do there's no
[ __ ] I should call the cops on your
ass
showed up sue me
we can to make hey hey super he's built
like a Lego piece covered in a cheese
yeah far away look like [ __ ] there you
get in there bro that's the man's body
right out of my [ __ ] back after
walking up all that mud I was straight
up when I got up there you idiot
I was very dancing look at my look at
the dislocation two dislocated my damn
rectum dislocate your lower body from
your upper body
don't take me on that [ __ ] bro to an
irregular Hey my favorite part you had
those brand-new brand-new shoes my house
they got rekt rekt man here's the worst
part though so we hi dude hold on before
he does the story I had to take the easy
path for this [ __ ] [ __ ] lesbian
aunt over here on the high brow the
shortcut shortcut yeah because you're
wearing hiking stuff dude try doing it
in [ __ ] cheerleading [ __ ] that's the
only [ __ ] I had in my car with some
men's you're kind of a younger man's
kind of clothing that's what I had you
said it was where soccer like a tire
well it was a at least at least probably
a mile of mud just uphill mud hello was
all hi
oh I remember you ever seen a passion of
the christ' you ever seen that
now imagine that in mud and short joints
mana boxy body pose mildly save that
they imagine Passion of Christ if he was
a gingerbread man I do that gingerbread
Behati bra I'll pull out that
straight-up [ __ ] G bread physique son
rage you know what I'm saying huh I told
John built like a Conestoga wagon you
freak
I'm built like a damn basement freezer
but once you walked up that [ __ ]
caboose started on he was just cruising
choo-choo and there's that son
Oh every time then I to take a piece of
coal and just put it in my butt
well here's the he's got a warm up bro
you're moving as if this [ __ ] Oregon
Trail of brendensen couldn't get any
shittier so first of all the guy takes
me on this [ __ ] thing I thought was
gonna get raped at one point very
sketchy very sketchy and even one of the
past it was like the the Natalie
Holloway very alarming for a mountain so
I was like what is this and the side had
been made by Brendan you knew it had
been because Holloway wasn't okay yeah
cuz I wasn't here I wasn't equipped for
the thing I really man
tell your trains to quit pushing that
[ __ ] I wasn't equipped for this kind
of [ __ ] you idiot when people ask you
for information you have to give them
information you can just say something
doesn't make any sense dude I was like
how's it gonna be muddy can we hike
today is it safe out there yeah man
we're something soccer style soccer
style this is one of you or hey well
here's the worst part it looks like that
I can and found someone [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey dude don't worry Parker [ __ ]
Subaru Outback you know you want a story
so Park Brendan instead of walking to
the park in front of the hike this has
to drive us to the front of the high
okay and immediately then if I can make
sure I had my rape whistle in my pocket
okay that's the first clue of a frickin
sex offender somebody's gonna drive you
up a height so we get partially up the
height and so he parks we get out we
walk out
we walk up the hike so then he takes us
down some back way in the shortcut right
Oh [ __ ] ants ooh over here couldn't
keep going dude I always blew out my
[ __ ] occipital x' man you're
delinquent you're passing plants was
gave huh my cossacks was [ __ ] rocked
bro because you couldn't put me on level
ground or at least just tell me to be
prepared do I need a walking stick all
of this nah nah man quit being a little
[ __ ] bruh okay here's the worst part so
we get off of the hill okay we get off
of the [ __ ] whatever this was dude
this Malvo Lance so Mountain it was
flowing the blood was flowing and I read
like a big brother for hedgehogs went by
in a boat in a Pierrot that they made
out of a piece of birch so anyway we get
off the hike we're into a neighborhood
I'm like well this is we were even going
we keep walking I'm like a we close he's
like a man we're almost there
we keep hiking for about another 25
minutes to Brendan's house bro so we get
there and I'm like you what are we doing
here shortcut where's the car and he's
like oh [ __ ] man we [ __ ] drove there
and then I go you forgot yeah yeah no I
get I think the shortcut and then I go
dude just give me a ride back my car
dude goes my keys so that is the last
time I don't check TripAdvisor
[Laughter]
he's wearing huge dog boots he's wearing
those big waffle things on the boots man
yeah this guy's got me out there like
can't hang got me struck dude your
struggle City
oh look like a stripper on ice dude just
sent my mom a little
rona gift Rosie oh yeah would you send
her mask oh yeah
no but I can't I figured how much how to
take care of from the inside so I sent
some athletic green oh my lord your mama
is gonna be running marathons in no time
you talk about athletic greens and
ultimate daily all in one health drink
with 75 vitamins and minerals why well
that's exactly what I'm talking about
does your mama know it's in a powder
form you just mix in a little bit of
water and take that thing straight to
the dome dude half my family's in
recovery of course my mother knows it's
in powder form dude heck yeah athletic
greens it is a specialty little dust if
you will a morning dust it includes
prebiotics probiotics digestive enzyme
adaptogens superfoods and more giving
your one-stop-shop to help support your
body's nutritional needs across five
critical areas of health today athletic
greens provides convenient affordable
and tasty solution to fill the gaps in
yo diet because you know what one thing
I noticed when I get up in the morning
out it's like man am I gonna I want to
make sure I have the right stuff
throughout my diet but I have a glass of
water then I have a second glass put
that athletic green powder in for ice
cube in there what I like to do is to
make me feel better about myself after
that a Panda Express
I hit a double orange chicken scoop but
I've done it with some athletic greens
like okay okay not too bad we see what
he's doing minerals in there and some
orange chicken they're like we see what
you're doing yeah dog whether taking
steps towards a healthier lifestyle like
Feliz mom or an athlete pushing for a
better performance athletic greens takes
the guesswork out of everyday good
health why not just try it jump on over
to athletic greens calm /ke 80s and
claiming special offers today the
special offer baby you get you have to
see the special man 20 free travel packs
valued at $79 with your first purchase
that's athletic greens calm /ke 80s and
get the 20 free travel pack valued at
$79 with your first purchase
y'all sniff that stuff bro and then he
came over from britain wouldn't spend
any time with me he says he's going to
draw the whole time
and here's a video of Brendan drawing
while we play with his son in the disc
okay well my son beats the [ __ ] out of
him even though my son beating the [ __ ]
out of you drew that yeah
you can draw yeah I thought it was did
you see did you see my Easter and my
cookie look at my cookie that's pretty
damn cool already
I've always been able to draw too well
there's just easy he'll see you think
got real sad some somebody found black
chalk and drew a skeleton and then a
rabbit and then a bunch of pills I'm
like dude there's kids here you stupid
[ __ ] well I did have kind of a defeatist
edge I couldn't draw first of all
because my spine was dislocated from
mice in eleven different places from my
for your son [ __ ] so was struggling
his son's insane all right
he really is yeah and his legs go
different than his body broke he's crazy
bro hook of 200 rounds with you if
anybody wants to do he's like I want to
do 140 he's like don't worry two-minute
rounds so yeah pretty intense man what
do you guys do for Easter
yeah what'd you guys do after after
Brendan got busted there too and [ __ ]
what from you look like an artist on
house arrest
we at Barnard thank you for inviting me
brother it was fun that's a good point
damn you losing weight dog damn that's
true I broke my jump rope though you did
hey how'd you break a jump right did you
would you got any stepped on it no I did
not step on it no but please just a
snack elaborate more cuz suddenly I'm
off the hook for now
[ __ ] ham about height with a large
black man breaks a jump rope suddenly I
look like again Lewis and Clark bar over
here for a walk
damn they're in jump rope jump ropes are
hard to break yeah alright well I got it
Clips it once and then I was like oh
shoot or whatever both loves and I can't
jump anything it was like you got to
tape it back together use a lighter and
put it back together is it plastic or
not is it one of the plastics are you
could tie them it's all in ones mm-hmm
you could tie that you could tie it off
when you have to duck down when you jump
in that [ __ ] it's not it's just don't
use the handle just keep that one like
this your neck be sore yeah workout it
yeah your neck to be so everybody do cut
absolutely nothing what do you see the
family hating know everyone's back in
the bay you guys don't celebrate Easter
not really we do for the kids but since
its quarantined
nobody's going out Wow do you do
anything nicht I prep for an episode of
this past weekend record an episode of
this past weekend and then edited and
posted an episode of this past week and
then went to bed
thanks he is risen He is risen I went to
Brendan's for us Easter everybody I
should have brought him some pizza chin
did you do anything sadly I just stayed
home to you like that really Easter so
Easter not an Asian holiday I don't
think so do you guys do you guys
celebrate it's a religious holiday yeah
so yeah crazy for me a lot of people
sell but more that's good they don't
even celebrated what they celebrated but
they don't celebrated with like the
Easter Bunny and stuff right in that
crazy I didn't know that that they don't
celebrate they don't know they they
don't do like the Easter Bunny and stuff
in Mexico I don't I think they might not
have they probably a bunnies there cuz
they're buddies getting like the dead
I think there's his armadillos and no
kid wants eat something left mine
armadillo you know I mean yeah chocolate
armadillo I'm gonna have yeah I'll have
a small one but I'm only having one
piece yeah bring I'm still shocked at
your drumming really I when I when I
first was firing the kid I used to do
all the designs for the shirts you leave
my straw the shirts here from years to
three years Dan yeah Easter customs in
Mexico this blew my mind cuz you think
Mexico Christian you think a lot of you
think the Easter Bunny man yeah this is
written in wing-dings font no it's not
your fault man there's something whoever
wrote this site can we complain is there
a thing that email okay huh you think I
love Easter man Obama I didn't get to go
home I wanted to go home but I think
everybody just people aren't doing like
big get-togethers or anything people
were doing crawfish throw that like a
little bit of crawfish but and they did
Easter Egg calm but not like everybody
didn't come over I think people are just
kind of scared have you started wearing
a mask around town I wore masks Roman to
the grocery they said you have to now
you get in certain places you have to
yeah to get in here you have to but
these were all pre-recorded in win
February you know mr. Burton and I went
over to Britain's for Easter
what has anyone happen for another six
yeah it's crazy what they can do now
what else happened I can't believe I
didn't do anything oh you didn't do
anything cat you didn't do anything
Chappelle no honestly for God was Easter
to be honest John wick I've never seen
it before
our film man
six hours yeah it was good I only saw
the first one it is he still do his dog
died
no but watch two and three though you
should watch it Book of Eli is good
you'll see in that movie oh look at me
good you feel like that it's kind of
about Easter a little bit it's about
Easter it's about like a little bit a
blind man and Easter like vaguely
oh I don't is it guy blind yes off to
watch it again
yeah let's blind in the picture I have a
friend this bond he said it's not that
bad yeah they've been blind forever
he's price is kind of nice he said it's
uh yeah and it might just be his
disposition he's kind of a chill guy
just a positive guy yeah if you're like
aw [ __ ] I gotta get I gotta stay busy in
your blonde then I bet it would be like
[ __ ] you know yeah maybe like you have
you're like yeah like yeah just be
insane everything would seem like that
high cause imagine somebody taunting you
from 30 feet ahead of you comfortably
yeah and you're just wandering through
the woods like [ __ ] Elizabeth smart
dude nice i loved it was blabbers ends
its sometime he throw a little he'd
throw a little one a sugar baby yeah
sugar baby I'd encourage him up the
mountain with sugar dude he had a circle
baby and sometime it was even one of
those butterscotch try to throw one down
on the ground
yeah accidentally threw to and he went
picked up that damn mountain we made it
we made it dude who's this young lady
right here she's got a king in her
staying for us
hey guys we got a quick King arresting
it for you Easter egg painting yay or
nay we had a competition in our house
and we'd really love for you to weigh in
and tell us which one is your favorite
culture corner your opinion matters to I
opted for that Joe exotic now they can
draw yeah that's good I covered wanna
spray my favorite really creative you
think Garrett's is [ __ ] savage bro let
James garrison is next to level snitch
yeah that Donald Trump is fantastic I'll
take good covet Cove it's good and I
even like that basic duck right there
yeah I like that when that little pond
thought that little [ __ ] white bread
[ __ ] succulent darkwing duck side
piece that little [ __ ] light wing
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
alright let's vote in you got his feet
let's let's take the kingdom sing one
out of it off officer we all love that
one okay take that one out of it all so
you have the darkwing duck side piece
you got the Trump then you got the two
[ __ ] Joe exotics and kovin okay um
I'll just write y'all know what y'all
okay really but what do you got homie on
the jet ski to fire that one's also the
most difficult I think yeah
Garretson right there and there's bees
Gerrits and beautiful exotic ones pretty
good
beautiful man right there single guy
says that lemur yeah well yeah if that
pawnshop and had one lane we hear that
bootleg lemur and that's why you ratted
everybody out allegedly so we bid I'm
wrong on the lemurs I'm going James
garrison as well man I think just I'm
gonna go with the co vid 1 ok
yeah I'm gonna have to go with James to
Wow I think she did better artistically
but his was more original yeah that's a
good point once you start thinking of
why they did it
yeah or what's going on cuz it yeah yeah
cuz he's not the most popular character
either enjoy exact that's a unique take
Trump was kidding yeah it is but that
part of Joe exotic is one of the best
parts oh yeah yeah and the plane I had
the Thai girls why [ __ ] well then one of
the craziest thing I've heard about the
whole Joe exotic thing now is that the
producer was your this - Nikki talk - I
talked to a bunch of those people yeah I
guess the producer Eric good who made
the tiger King documentary he was giving
drugs and alcohol to all the people he
was interviewing a lot allegedly yeah
allegedly let a lot of them were in
recovery so he like they fell off the
wagon and he got a bunch of information
out of them sounds like there's a bunch
of sketchy stuff involved that no one
really wants it sounds like he did his
job it sounds like at every level of
this entire thing somebody was screw
somebody it's like a pyramid scheme that
one dude then Annie that's not real
her boyfriend was there they flute they
paid her that's crazy
faked it all all right I got James
garrison we got two for James Garretson
I got Corona Nick Jed definitely games
Garretson about four feet in here - now
I had Trump immediately Wow Trump once
again yeah that one is good eggs are
[ __ ] tough to draw on they're all
tiny gotta paint them - yeah you gotta
get one of them big stretch eggs man
they make ostrich bring ostrich eggs
yeah [ __ ] that's a good idea you could
really they're more different in here
comes a young man here comes Joe exotics
third Rodriguez aka Nicky rod and I got
a key here singer for y'all getting a
puppy they're in quarantine oh I like
the commitment or not - oh he's oh oh
he's five Nicky rod that's a nice animal
right down what is that animal
Frenchie yep French Bulldog boo no such
emits though yeah it looks like a little
deer like a fat baby D yeah I have a
[ __ ] you might do you hear you might
have bought a reindeer on now that's a
pet if you want to give wild during the
teen rough bus bus out [ __ ] want a
Santa's little helpers yeah yeah hey
animals nose right if I can see what's
up dude he's cute is [ __ ] I'm like King
getting a puppy cuz you got nothing else
to do might as well train that thing
that's a good point and you got a buddy
asleep with you that should be dope I'm
sorry you don't get a dog cat I mean no
I like animals but after the quarantine
as long as you keep the animal and
you're continuously taking care of them
that's great
but I have a feeling people are gonna
give back those quarantine animals
really yeah when people started getting
back to their lives because the only
reason why a lot of people want animals
now is cuz they have nothing to do you
know they're just using the animals yeah
it's like it's like one big tiger king
it's like everybody Joe exotic hopefully
they don't shoot in the face hopefully
yeah Joe exotic killed those Tigers do
you see the bonus episode I haven't seen
yet is he getting the talk about how he
killed the Tigers like the healthy
Tigers but he needed the space they just
called him up to the cage and show them
the heads video of it or no it's alleged
mm I think that video but he admitted to
it in jail he is on the general call
admitted to it what's interesting is
they had like the five main characters
and Joel McHale was the host and he
asked all of them goes [ __ ] Joe exotic
be in jail all of them including the
people are close with like yes he did
some horrible stuff man and all of them
even people who defend him that he
should be in jail [ __ ] I gotta watch
that man cuz what is your name what is
joel mchale doing with it that was a
host but what is it like a after show or
season after show yeah knows but it's
all face time you know we've been better
if it was in person like a real Love &
Hip Hop reunion they just fought and
[ __ ] like a live tiger did was James
garrison on there
she was an either some people declined
the interview but like the main people
were his little thought side piece with
the missing teeth yet he's a grill now
oh yes teeth fix and he has a fiancee it
wasn't gay no he wasn't gay I'm saying
man I voted this for a decade you called
that from the jump
yeah about a quarter of a decade now
I've been arguing this listen I tell I
tell you right now don't put me around
Tiger cuz officer there's something
magical cuz them boys want to play those
times are so bad they start sucking dick
okay
but don't bring around the Tigers bro
know what's gonna happen the Tigers
nothing to do with the tooth and you put
that majestic tiger dude I don't know
what's gonna happen no I never wand over
those short-shorts you on the Hydra that
you told me to bring you freakin used me
let me see this dude he said to bay club
but this is a kingdom it's drug induced
homosexuality is what I've been talking
about for a quarter of a decade and you
freaks don't know what's going on called
it co do when he was on drugs he's like
[Laughter]
I'm just telling you this okay no it's
not I'm not gay if you're high and you
meet a guy off the 101 and suck his dick
from at I would never suck a man's face
much okay
I would never suck some person's did if
I'm suckin anybody's dick it's mom did
okay first of all and you can write that
down and second of all I'm just sayin at
a certain point with drug use there gets
a point where it doesn't matter what's
going on and it's not gay it's just
drug-induced homosexuality I hear your
brother loud and clear so at 2:00 a.m.
everybody's buddies 3:00 a.m. is still
drugged there's not as many buddies
around 4:00 a.m. dude dicks and bucks
there's one buddy there's drugs and
everybody does get the drugs yeah and
you do it by any means necessary
everybody's looking for something warm
bro man on fire you're suckin dick
it's different is saying at those hours
it gets different yeah you know it's
that witching hour
good I never did anything free just I
hear good I've said it before if I was
gay bra would be [ __ ] shocked to do
I'm saying I'm sorry if I saw me dating
a man I would call the police you free
yes I would baby pretty happy you're the
one who's the [ __ ] hillside banglar
who's [ __ ] sneaking men out in a
frickin soggy terrain and watching him
getting stuck in mud okay
and then when that didn't work for you
the oh I accidentally took us back to my
place you're the one good defense about
Joy's I do this I gave your highness
[ __ ] you have no money and you need
[ __ ] Louisiana it's a hot summer day
and your shirts off your convertible and
you have cheeks all I'm saying is dude
don't David dukes is there and he saw
him in hats and they sell out there was
two ads people only bought two and also
what I'm telling you right now is you're
not listening no I again is that you're
going to try and molest a friend be able
to close the deal bro you can't even
close the [ __ ] deal you got me stuck
in the mud I was a lot of meth and then
I rest my case if that's the way that's
the truth Roe then it comes down to the
drugs man dude I said right since day
one hillside banglar strikes again bro
strikes again ran out of maps thank you
bye dick sighs yeah uh me over there
trying to light a butterscotch up in a
crack pipe in your veins
I'm gonna do what that Brendon
name's Jesse I'm from College Station
Texas but I'm currently driving across
country man moving out of here to
California during these Corona times
this is the most boring [ __ ] drive
ever
anyway I keep seeing all these signs so
I got a debate club for you where you
guys think about these roadside
attractions keep seeing these billboards
for something called the thing some [ __ ]
about some boy wall while this [ __ ]
looks like an alien
I don't even know man love the content
fellas love watching the podcast also do
you got any advice for a southern man
moving out here to the California let me
know what's up man hey guys shall take
it easy keep doing good work gang yeah
bro college station not gonna I got a
cousin my cousin goes to school there he
did he did he's an adult now but he went
to school there if I can do it all over
again I would played college ball Texas
A&M really yep I have the chance and
didn't go that would be in the place why
what makes you say that that's just such
a dope college town for college football
God man we I think I played there twice
and it's just magical damn so big the
freakin stadium so big it's just like a
sea of people
damn yeah yeah they have uh they don't
get a lot of credit they don't really
get a lot of focus because they're over
there because Texas has so many schools
but they were a big dog for a while and
then they have the Florida State coach
now they're gonna be back for sure who
went did dak Prescott go there now he
went to Ohio you know he went to
Mississippi State oh yeah that's right
come on
Manziel went there I mean I went there
they have some ballers the receiver for
Tampa Bay went there Von Miller yes how
do you go Jim by Fantana
yeah Jimbo Fisher's the coach now oh
okay no they've had some ball yeah it's
my favorite place to play when I play
there Evans went there that's right yeah
that's why I say the receivers from
Tampa he's a ball hog yeah him and Tom
Brady
come on son that could be wild when I
when I I played there twice and when I
played there
I remember President Bush would show up
nowheres
there would be Secret Service there I'm
like what the [ __ ] cuz we do a
walk-through you know the night before
we get down like my Secret Service did
when President Bush was out there
watching us then snitch was he yeah I
wouldn't be shocked man he was selling
the place awesome over time
did y'all copy purified fumbled the ball
who was Bobby purify running back and
where is he now can we see where he's at
he's in Colorado Springs I think yes
did you play with him yeah so you played
fullback right yeah
damn that's crazy man so when full bat
you have to block pot huh yeah blocking
catch is it fun blocking or not not
really I mean you just get a CT all the
time dude
yeah and literally the guy where they
like a run into that guy so this guy can
look cool dude you were like on the hunt
for CT because it's like if you didn't
get it in football you like aw I'm gonna
find it somewhere he went I mean you
just keep house mr. CT cuz I was playing
fullback and running into large man that
was my job and then yeah yeah and my mom
and my histories the gay one that's the
crazy part a sudden yeah
Bobby purifying what happened he took
his own life no hell no jail for
emitting the 12,000 our theft he's the
nicest guy man was he Oh such a good
dude 12,000 anybody could try and steal
that such good dude you don't say I mean
it says is that jailable he probably
released now cuz if I yeah man I was mr.
CT cuz football and I was the captain a
special team so I I was the wedge
breaker so I've run in and break the
wedge on kickoff and I went from that to
UFC they got rid of wedge breakers cuz
it was so so dang I was the guy I always
mister wedge breaker and then I used to
light dudes up and then teams like oh
that's what you want to do they'd put
big tackles there so I'd have to run
into the big top oh the biggest white
dudes and dude and now you're doing a
misguided hiking up a hiking tour guy
you finish your butterscotch what else
not like it man Brennan's butterscotch
getaway
I can market that yeah should we do a
little sync my ink oh yeah I better get
tatted up Thursday are you really yeah I
saw you looking for I got a tat dude I
got the guy here's Eddie Bravo he looks
like Eddie Bravo with my hair feels
forehead like Eddie Bravo dude first of
all it was the king of sting it
flattered her oh yeah what's a king of
singing you've [ __ ] rare youtube
links hey can't you're seeing at 5g
cause Corona yeah
well I would definitely people should
talk I'm not gonna be shocked if it did
no it didn't it didn't but there's some
people that say a dead Brendon let's
hear what uh it's only in five come yeah
[Laughter]
yeah let's see what this guy's for you
boys I'm confused wrong with that that's
hilarious last but not least
[Laughter]
beach boy you want to smooth a baby
great line by the way thank you yes ah
yeah great tattoos man does anybody get
straight mom i straight mom I'm confused
straight mom was where was it I was calf
was there rumor as mom wasn't straight
straighten the in the town straight
mom's straight mommy straight mom
straight mom his calf he was cast over
mom mom I'm upside down is Wow
straight mom that's a confusing one
he said he's like a walking dad joke of
tattoos so like there's something there
about straight mom st ra IG HT m om
straight mom is that he spell straight
mm-hmm yeah I knew it was you're waiting
for the answer to bring the big toes
like it's just great mom I don't know
what that is
straight mom mmm on his calf funniest
ones the hamstring and the piggy I'm
with the hamstrings got a straight mom
and then the camel atoll Kemp camel toe
yeah camel toe is great that hamstrings
unbelievable not the best artwork in the
Caribbeans you know well you got lemon
yeah a lot of artists down there are two
città probably on the run from stuff I
mean once you get down to the islands
Key West Caribbean I mean you can't even
the Caribbean is great unless you want
something then you have to wait forever
to get it like I remember trying to get
a fish dinner over there and uh and they
had to go wake the man up they put us in
the restaurant way to sit in there for
40 minutes we got the chef then they
come back I'll in life those two hours
and ten minutes
we're been in Costa Rica furiosa Rica
huh you're burning Costa Rica yeah
filled with [ __ ] is it oh dude I
walked into bars just [ __ ] island you'd
love in it never had it was like a shark
frenzy just grabbing my dick yeah it's
terrible over this guy's issue
prostitution is legal in Costa Rica
that's why burnin it's not even some
would say it's the funnest time are you
on a crocodile tour do you dick suck in
a crocodile tour that's living brother
then go ziplining no naked
no dude Costa Rica's living you need to
get your mind out of the gutter brother
you need to get to church before
everything started shutting down pretty
much fill it up now got some leg hair
growing back
what'd you get tattoo so pretty much
having gumball machine full of different
designs in there I'll pop this little
frog so what do you guys think Kim
intersting it get what you get tattoos
wow dude get what you get that'd be fun
you know Chin's gonna get a neck tattoo
his birthday is Friday are you and he's
always won a neck tattoo when so mean
chin I mean chin have matching tattoos
and when we're in Dublin him my brother
me got matching tattoos she wanted to
get on his neck and the dude goes what
the artist goes you want to do what he's
I want the tattoo on my neck he goes
dude for your first one I do in your
neck he refused to do it I was messed up
Wow but I guess Yakuza [ __ ] goes Yakuza
yeah but we found out we got a guy who's
willing to do it ginger said you
you said you decide what you want to
know I'll figure out but I think I know
what you know I don't like to tell
people my tattoos a fish a fish we want
to like a goldfish what do you think a
fish
no just a fish that's swimming like this
mm-hmm oh yeah like like a barracuda
no no just a regular fishing like a
piranha huh a regular fish man it's just
too small
you want like a like how much do you
feel like a nice clean trout a black
trout maybe solid black cotton mahi-mahi
you want a black fish maybe
hell yeah do do want I could see you
having a my a my on you on the side of
your on the side you get a swordfish
get the arm get the better mundi
Australian fish do get that big old
grouper on your fish sucking on your
throat - David you get a sucker fish
yeah yeah yeah get that tank cleaner
Siamese fighting fish I saw those was
actually look cool that's what the tails
are would be waiting yeah fins like yes
yes on they look cool I like that idea
that sounds like a really neat idea dude
you ever got two Siamese fish together
mmm I haven't dude it straight up fish
cockfighting well oh you put they don't
like each other through around to the
same fish why would I do we fight to the
death
why would you do it cuz I was a young
kid with no money I needed entertainment
yeah I had a fish fight no money but you
had your exotic fish maybe not that
exotic dude where did you grow if two
Japanese fighting fish bro dude I ran a
pretty rough skin kids paid a lot of
money see those Siamese fish died yeah
dude how are you able to happen upon
these rare fish it's not rare dude
they're in every [ __ ] first place you
went into are they really they sell them
at Walmart we would we would combine
them in Walmart it was
regret regretful now but yeah we would
go in high school we put fish together
and they kill each other in there but
also awesome
we sat on them yeah that's what we're
doing bet on them candy Walmart's what
do people give so much [ __ ] to Walmart
Walmart's [ __ ] amazing bro you can go
in Walmart and be in there for twenty
hours if you want you stay the night
that crazy
you could be in there for 20 hours also
they have everything have fun
do you know guns go shooting snacks
slider planets get a plant return it you
have nice lunch there eat lunch bro
there's a lot you can do and here's uh
related okay here we go with the young
man right here frozen but anyways I got
a debate club for yo ass
[Laughter]
Walmart or Target I mean you know
Walmart you go you little he goes on a
good pointer i get clowned as a kid in
elementary school my mom called it
tarjay uh-huh like fancy yeah I kept
calling it tarjay my escort calling Nick
actually the place where I got that
couch was missing pieces they were all
there it looks comfy perfect size to
Nick good call and I'm getting black
yeah never gonna replace Dara like yeah
you guys gonna get a replacement for
Derrick oh it's just Kat sorry usually
joke again I'll be doing this show and
you're rocking the blue Cortez oh yeah
my my dad that was in prison for 17
years did he get busted for fighting
fish for drugs
did he really what kind of drugs was it
he was around when the crack up through
slinging that crack slinging that crack
was it was a gang member he wasn't
really into the gangs he was more so
into like the drug the money and how
much time did he get he did so he has a
crazy story so he did 13 years he
studied law and got himself out of
prison Wow
yeah so he's smart distances yeah so
because he got he got life for attempted
murder but he didn't do it yeah but uh
he studied long enough drugs found out
the system [ __ ] up and not only did my
daddy release but a bunch of other
inmates got oh yeah that's what I guess
when you get live someone specific has
to sign off for it and that person did
it so my dad caught that now yeah it's
like a we're like we're building a
relationship does he still do drugs or
anything
still dudes clean now yes cleaned out
yeah it's doing good was he using drugs
or he was just selling drone I'm selling
it yeah yeah just wasn't a lot of stuff
for black oh there was a lot of stuff
for black men to sit they didn't have a
lot of business opportunity though you
know you got it you know what I'm saying
I get that I don't think when I was
growing up they didn't have like a lot
of black guys that were like doctors in
our town and stuff like that or like
business owners
I think drugs was like a easy thing you
could sell you know he said when the
crack epidemic hit he said was crazy the
same he said you had two chances in like
seven out of the ten houses either
someone's doing it or selling it damn
that's how if that's what you're
surrounded by you involved in the
business yeah what you need is to me
that's just smoking crack and not in but
not a businessman what else you got get
us out of this race see you at some Bay
Club
with the last got 100 Walmart or Target
Oh Oh targets a little fancy I'm more of
a tarjay guys my mom called it but RJ's
more for women I feel like women more go
to Target anybody could go to Walmart
you can go to Walmart to get a boat you
can go to Walmart to get a Bible I feel
like more meth addicts would dig Walmart
it's more kind of like it's free-for-all
yeah what market kind of place if you're
in a smaller area like can you go to the
Walmart it's kind of like something to
do they're all the same
also Walmart's are just kind of flea
markets got their [ __ ] together you know
yeah it's kind of like the clothing
section I always kind of liked it they
always have like Florida State gear and
stuff they always had like kind of a
couple of colleges and stuff yeah they
did I get Christmas you go get that you
get your brother or sisters you always
get an Oklahoma Sooners shirt yeah yeah
Crimson Tide random teams yeah you get
Hanes socks I like that I like both but
I'm more of a tarjay man really yeah my
son loves Target yeah I guess target
looks a little bit more organized it's
smaller I feel like it's small at
Walmart's massive man yeah exhausted
blocking that thing you can get to
hydrate it in there you'll find people
just [ __ ] passed out people are
sitting in lawn chairs yeah yeah that's
one thing I do like well you can get it
you can get to like the second or third
realm in there and you can know somebody
[ __ ] about Walmart beyond yeah yeah dude
they'll have somebody hooking like
brewing their own water cooking steaks
on dude it was crazy because they do
like ever like before every shift they
do this like weird chant I can't tell it
but they do this like weird chants
awkward but yeah I last about a week
really yeah what didn't you like about
it now why'd you only last a week I mean
I was just [ __ ] I was like what the
[ __ ] my it was I don't just seem to
Coulter to me Walmart cult yeah that's
what it seems like how did you get out
of there dude it takes forever to get
out of there here's the thing though is
that Walmart
I love Walmart I think if I can go back
in time and work somewhere and work at
Walmart for a cup
months really I loved it man I've worked
at Home Depot I could see you at Home
Depot yeah with that launch cape on yeah
and you eat the churros
[Laughter]
can't start with your break dude dude
Costco to Costco has some good food man
the pizza I'm sure Rose I don't go to
Costco but I do sometimes I used to go
to Walmart and they're good shrimp
scampi I always thought that Costco is
an elite club and get you and I know can
you yeah I get you plus one I'll go in
yeah all right I'll take Nick Thanks
Walmart allows people to tamp in their
parking lot for like travelers and stuff
I did it when I moved out here in my car
Wow any advice for the guy Walmart if
you should looking for a place to see
sleep Walmart I love that I didn't know
that I've always wondered to I'm the
dude it's like oh I'll go park in like a
scary area and just be real quiet
I'm just working from the house and
figure it out who does parking lot did
you yeah I could see you doing that in
an Impala really yeah I'm not a bloody
nose for what were you were they doing
like a grand opening or some in the
morning you would be the first one in no
I don't know my nose won't stop bleeding
I'll never forget that Oh probably
because of any one of your life paths
bro football you bet like at that point
the CT he has to if I can really be
setting in you're sitting outside of a
hooter for the nose or was trying to
drain out what do young Britons like I'm
gonna block it in
[Laughter]
look because second cousin is legal
first cousin is what is not legal and we
do have to get that out there because
there's a lot of misinformation that the
rule in Louisiana it's the rule
everywhere first cousin we look this up
to Nick you legally have sex you the
first cousin I know the answer's no but
we can do it you have answers no
information but you do the brother okay
can never know Chapelle yeah that's do
when you look like every one of your
stories so you should better start I can
have some information to support your
sex I hear Chapelle okay some state sex
between first cousins is prohibited in
some states yeah legality of incest and
look at that color chart let's get to
the color chart we don't want to trick
Brennan but things in there literally
not hey wifey Oh knows the strict
details on sleeping with your cousin I
have no idea are you gonna blame it on
meth again ass again dude you don't know
what you can do when you're high your
cousins they're running low on product
you [ __ ] your cuz it dude drug-induced
assess you and I'm telling you it's how
it start you're gonna start taking some
responsibility for your choices bro now
I'm just saying that do some places you
get the death penalty yeah that's that
Middle East area and also Africa Middle
East in some parts of Africa it looks
like frowned upon cans and Zabar where
is that what about in America can we
just look at America America is a kind
of orange and red on some of the west
coast just leaked out yeah let's even
just let's just go back to whatever that
first thing was this does is about
incest if we can incest laws and charges
the crime of incest is committed we know
what happens is it is it a crime between
adults what about that almost all states
criminalize incest between adult
relatives some legal scholars have
argued that incest
laws apply to adults should be rethought
I see I could see that I think a lot of
it too because if you get with a family
member you have a baby it has a high
likelihood of being a [ __ ] baby that's
one of the main reasons that's one of
the main reasons man in the United
States what does that say Nick second
cousins are legally allowed to marry in
every state praise God brother well I'm
just saying because here's one of the
things is some people they don't live
they should not live close to anybody
like they didn't have cars they didn't
have so it's like you could only you
know you're not gonna walk over probably
20 miles to have sex with someone so you
got to think and most of that your
family live enclosed so that's why they
made the laws was because yeah babies
were coming out a little while
Alabama allows first cousin marriage a
lot of them do Alaska
yes Arizona yes California yes Colorado
yes that's disappointing Colorado then I
would not [ __ ] my first cousin at high
altitude right okay you are really
Louisiana apparently get some sort of
refund a few minutes waiting first
cousins is not allowed welcome to the
future brother we are laying the path
that's why I feel moved to telephone I'm
not gonna go home for Easter this Perona
virus or because like just like a
warrant out for your arrest sleep with
you young cousin what else you got me
last debate club it's a striking though
we'll be doing Nick I want to go through
and at least answer some of these
people's questions because I don't think
we've answered any the guy said by the
foot or fruit roll-up okay oh listen
yeah I'm more of a quality over quantity
the fruit by the foot it's a foot
[ __ ] long roll of [ __ ] fruit
roll-up it's like a cheap fruit roll-up
I got thick stiff fruit roll-up and you
take it out of that package and it's
[ __ ] tight you roll that [ __ ] out
yeah and I still I still roll it up
I said what stick to the roof of your
mouth like a retainer I love that I
never had a lie we didn't have fruit
roll-ups
they're expensive man they were
definitely more of a higher-end treat
they were fruit by the foot was cheap oh
you get that anywhere you get that on
the [ __ ] Street yeah you never did
have seven feet of it roll-ups always
advertise there is shapes inside it that
you could peel out and you can peel that
[ __ ] out no one ever did yeah you could
peel it out to be all deformed all too
hard on one end of the star or they had
the tongue tattoos yeah that's right
what was that they had like a little
imprint of like animals and stuff like
that where if you keep it on your tongue
for long enough you'll get like the
marking on your tongue so it looks like
a tattoo oh my god hey how about my son
and that sounds like a scam doesn't it
what kid would have kids will fall for
[ __ ] anything dude dude how about
Murray how about my son got warheads for
Easter oh yeah remember warheads man I
don't know they still made a my son gum
like what the [ __ ] do they try them
there's those little [ __ ] warheads but
they are not like when we were kids more
kids we eat those warheads dude you
gonna miss him for two days oh the first
batch of warheads that ever came out
brother that hot batch dude one of my
friends had one and he couldn't open his
eyes for almost two days couldn't open
his eyes we had a ton of stories like
that we had to hold his eyes open to
look at him those more has a different
level something talked Sandra that did
the first ones that came out somebody
had one you have to split it up I
remember people would split it it ruin
your day yeah it was so much fun oh yeah
bro remember I had like a little bit of
dust on the outside of that where can we
get those vintage warheads the remote
remember the big jaw breakers you'd lick
them so much your tongue would start to
bleed and you get to the middle and
they'd be like some weird gushy sauce
sauce no you never made it that far
this episode is disgusting about sex and
perversion and this supposed to be our
Easter episode but hold on we haven't
helped anybody yeah we did
thank you hi I want the [ __ ] on a
roof I wrote some [ __ ] okay I'm a
fruit roll man okay
I'll go for fruit roll-ups and I'm
really feeling froggy and I want to be
get savvy with it I'm going gushers all
goddamn day I put that gun off that
thing bus in my mouth oh oh that sweet
syrup rolls down my throat to drink
laughs you see start deep down some
notches for grape gosh what are you
saying dude all grape Guster's look the
same dude can't work with this when is
this stop bro you wanna make o an hour
and it can I sleep with my first console
part of it I wasn't offended your hatch
and we need to let you see I told you
that it's legal dude I just saying there
are certain places have different like
will you tell your cousin equipment
anyone okay we'll help everybody
the guy was in the car and he wanted to
know something he was driving remember o
king you're staying at roadside
attractions I totally forgot about two
roadside attractions dude those are just
people on math Greenup [ __ ] to make
money that's what it is the biggest
dinosaur in the world yeah and they have
it right there outside of uh it's about
quarterly every state has its problem
yeah but different ones there's more
than one there's dinosaurs were
everywhere hey you know that you think
I'm a just America head dinosaurs oh my
god bro that's crazy dude if you're one
of the [ __ ] dinosaur international
dinosaur deniers that's the oldest trick
in the ignorance book let me tell you
man roadside attractions [ __ ] yeah dude
yeah they make time fly by yeah I get
myself one [ __ ] although snack sized
bags of Cheetos and I go look at the
biggest beaver in the world yeah listen
brother that is living toss some tobacco
my lip that's living man yeah where else
she gonna see someone with the largest
jar of [ __ ] humor
saliva pick up a slim jim on those
little lot lizards yeah it's a good time
bro you got to get out there man where
else you gonna just see somebody who
[ __ ] decapitated her own leg and
turns it into a bird feeder do you pull
off the interstate can get some damn gas
hey come and go yeah those coming goes
great yeah dude heavy on the come
brother I was representing a [ __ ]
stop place they get gas and cheetos bro
every place you're at yeah because you
guys are rotting my mind two hours
trying to figure out you [ __ ] your
cousin or not I don't have any first
cousins dude say that your therapist all
right the answer's nah man ain't cool
you guys are what else you got
can you play a gospel song or something
this one's pretty wholesome King in the
sting this is Dave coming from Boston
had a couple throw backs for you
regarding toys Theo hate to leave you
out of this I know your mother didn't
love you Brendan how you probably
remember some of these gems yeah but I
got a king in the sting for you ninja
turtles hey oh dude Wow my pet monster
was my ultimate favorite gift as a kid
really ah dude my dad got it for me me
and my brother used to fight over that
thing came with the chains we lost one
the chain so he only had one chain on
and there was a movie and a cartoon my
pet monster oh it's my favorite gift as
a kid then I had the whole Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles collection as well
mmm I even had the van ID the blimp then
a blimp where you'd fit all the action
figures in it really hot well they don't
make toys like that anymore my favorite
monster this guy's called ya know my cat
monster it's my favorite gift here's the
same nose as Theo
well like as long as I'm as long as I'm
your second favorite monster the little
toys were dumped I actually would even I
would go back and buy some of them I
would actually really did look at this
is the commercial my pet monster there's
not much to do with him as you can tell
as for whites only there was one black
kid away with somebody else's my pet mom
it was get out the prequel yeah what
this is early get whole circle here
full circle man just like that shitty
hike well do we help anyone really I
think III honestly [ __ ] we there's so
many things we didn't answer for people
here's what I would say to the guy
driving across country man do not one
time I had all my cash right and so I
stopped at a rest area I've been eating
nodos which were kind of a regional kind
of upper at the time and uh I put all my
cash into my underpants said I'm gonna
leave in my cars and my life savings I
was moving out the university Arizona to
go to college and I forgot it was in
there I went just say I went in
something like the floor in this it was
a one of the biggest gas station come
here you know we'll shoot your you know
we'll shoot your buddy in the face pull
over you know like oh man I don't have a
buddy but I'll [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
buy a couple almond joys and watch the
fun you know I'll buy a scores bar and
watch some clothes like some creep but
I'll sit in my car and watch so anyway I
fell asleep in there I fell asleep like
40 minutes right got up forgot that all
my cash was in my underpants and it fell
out of my pant leg in a gas station
no $1,100 so then I lost it couldn't
find it so then literally for the next
two hours I'm wandering around this gas
station asking people strangers if they
found $1,100 in cash huh how'd you get
the Arizona Playboy I had to stop yeah I
knew
now pastor yet I had to sleep in El Paso
in my car one night and then my step guy
came and gave me gas money when he said
you were gonna go to the University
Arizona I mean hanging out there [ __ ]
school great I live for one semester man
[ __ ] yeah okay I went into class man
bear down yeah did you guys play them no
mmm you just play Colorado State right
out of conference but when I was at
Colorado State was out of conference
yeah cuz their mount their Mountain West
and we're big 12 I feel like every game
I see a Colorado they would play we beat
them against Colorado State it would be
the seventh overtime 53 to 51 good games
yep but my high showdown son
there's always out of conference though
damn the little brother used to beat the
[ __ ] out of really every year still do
who beat you guys a lot Texas Oklahoma
who's y'all playing it's major
Applewhite oh yeah y'all did yeah good
call in Vince Young damn we played Vince
Young and they had Cedric Benson and
they beat us 52 3 big 12 championship
then we played Oklahoma the following
year and I played against Jason White
and Adrian Peterson you go - Trophy
winners they beat us 72 three damn
planet Kansas City Chiefs team at
halftime do y'all still think y'all can
come back nope that's why I'm gonna
coach do it you think go out there now
have some fun I guess I'd be that guys
like we're gonna [ __ ] 42 nothing a
half the ha we need a trick play six
pointer yeah kind of shooting at six
point a dog I wish they should have a
way that you can get back in the game
you know those were bombers were they
yeah you know Qin's birthday's Friday
huh Chinn turns 43 on Friday really in
two months right and two months not
Friday there
deeming myself that's crazy man
what are you want to celebrate what was
that he's gonna be working yeah we're
gonna celebrate our work though we're
gonna do a little party okay yeah maybe
we'll try and do something next week for
you oh you guys doing something fighter
in the kid cuz you ask a particular
product okay well I don't know what
birthday we have coming up next one
scats
or do you don't you don't say it mine is
in the summer oh I remember what I
remember birthdays is it it's July 3rd
oh it's coming up then when George
Chapelle January 20 called are you sure
bail I'm 33 are you wrong as [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah I thought he was like 26 I
thought he's older than that I thought
to the gym with him okay that's it he
dated this hot girl at work to the
seafood restaurant she was so she was
races at all I don't know but I'll say
this she she was very white she had like
white you ever meet like a person who's
born like white hair you know every now
and then unless somebody's born with
like snow my hair yeah yeah who's like
yes she was like hell by now he wonder
why yeah he's like whiten it up a little
you were white shirts you wear white
stuff you know she would just say white
white white white dank so yeah cats the
next birthday then day after Christmas I
mean how could you ever feel really
wanted in the world born after the Jesus
day man
man that cleanup hitter right there lots
of lots of double-double gifts this is
Christmas ember at least if you ever
ever become a school shooter or
something for an adult school okay yeah
we just would stay our support at least
understanding why you did it cuz people
said oh this is this key discounts for
two years
it's underdog that's how that's how we
do here man it's underdogs only sure we
can get a lot of weird [ __ ] sent in for
cat's birthday oh my god yes
like no explanation no explanation
sometimes they'll use something else as
like reference Oh a little bit like aa
chapstick or like a small hat like a bad
ball like a match check out this hog
handle this unboxing video speaking of
unboxing you know what we're used to
self coffins how crazy is that
not crazy true can you look at it go get
that thick Iran get you that blue thick
we had our own Jesse yeah rip my drivi
clowning the dead guy no no just that
[ __ ] thick boy casket
caskets ghosts Oh what does it call gas
cats cats cats cats doesn't work don't
worry about it hang in the stang skit
damn you get that tie-dye hitter look at
the colors cooking on the tie light
color see the colors too far left
oh it's beautiful it's not what kind of
[ __ ] Fox gonna get a tie-dye
oh that's we put the ashes oh it's
caramelized - oh you can put your ashes
in the fabergé egg god that's nice mmm
wonder what I want to be in mmm I want
to be in like a something the dog and
run around with every now and then it's
a people be like oh [ __ ] it just brought
do in the room yeah like a bone like
yeah like at some type of a treat or
something we crazy though right like a
greeny but with your ashes yeah let me
see like some kind of fun - wait did we
answer everything people wanted though I
took we missed something I think that's
kind of the fun of the show they never
get answered but Easter egg painting
we're Pro it getting a puppy during
quarantine King it roadside attractions
King um a lot of King in Walmart it's
very rare we sting [ __ ] fruit by the
foot or fruit roll-ups over by the foot
Walmart over target well that's how we
did hard okay no I liked RJ over Walmart
yeah I want that on the record
I can't listen to a man call it RJ over
and over again but I like Walmart I like
the fact that you can fish you can
[ __ ] cast out into the [ __ ]
distance anymore and see if you pissed
somebody off might hit a kid good [ __ ]
him no one gives a [ __ ] but if you bring
your kid to Walmart and home expecting
to get roughed up a little bit by the
locals but that was always the best
summer Hannah McKay gone by and they had
that big thing of balls they were put in
the middle of Walmart for no reason it
was like 40 cents for one of these balls
right and you guys hammam at everybody
gone by
that's right they said those big that
cage full of all I think was insane
and there be somebody stuck in there
[Laughter]
throw a ball out dude and I'll throw
some bread and water in you creep quit
crying don't be a ball well Brennan and
Theo fighter and wait I gotta go in and
go hard in the paint I do not think I am
in Flo black rifle coffee I'm ready to
go
I need a sponsor I am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts Flo is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls leather Instagram famous damn
okay like a fresh off keto see a red
like Andrew Santino right every Sunday
hit like the great Bambino gonna take
the case oh and the case Cerritos but
everything's gonna be fine got a pack of
matches in his pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
traffic couldn't beat em quit playin
like that's in DoDEA's you don't want
the smoke like Joey Diaz meaning y'all
edible just got my eyebrows threaded and
I'm feelin incredible Brit and Sun him
me up he said it's too loud in the club
can you pick me
King in the state and the sting bee
sting
King King King King another state got of
bees in the truck got that cheese on a
string
and the sting king and the stinking and
the sting bee sting crack king king in a
sting a king and the sting
got that cheese on a string
Brendan and do fighter in Creole
shoutout New Orleans and shout out to Co
Colorado more specifically Boulder
Brendan came in with a chip on his
shoulder but is still gold and yet it
still fire if you don't like King
Aniston you're a liar Brenda's got like
a thousand different hustles one of
them's at Nordstrom Rack go and tie
yours black rifle coffee we hear you
loud and clear your son on the email
like please get me out of here is way
too loud in here watching the Irishman
eating pizza drinking half a beer now on
the Theo von looking like the type of
dude the trans Rita songs smoking
cigarettes for the snapback on let's a
hit the [ __ ] in turn snapchat on it's
all go we still mess with you 18:11 Pico
Boulevard go get the head Derek and cat
y'all doing great Thursday upload not a
minute late y'all wanted to rap ahead a
demonstrate brand new studio y'all
feelin great putting Chris Delano in
this place now let's go and get chin I
paint a sting
and the sting
and the sting bee sting crack
and the stinger a king and then stay
back
traffic gotta cheese on a string ducky
is a sting King in the sting came in the
sting bee sting Rat King
in a sting a king and the state gotta
beez in the trap gotta cheese on a
string
[Music]